[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes plus nikos ou de
benjamin castaldi
voilà j'aime bien le dire benjamin il
est là et si aussi avait pas dit qu
aller les deux se trouvaient ils sont
aussi cool donc quand il présente voilà
ça fait pas si vous deviez en choisir
qu'un panel à castaldi
j'ai plus d'affinités j'aimerais ce que
je ne connais plus d'accord om ou psg à
vous avez mis 10 mai gemini ça c'est un
petit coucou pour alesi dans la ville de
nice et ma vieille fille est née à nice
donc tee shirt
quand on a vu ni chez vous a dit c'est
un petit coucou pour la ville de nice se
dit ça doit être un petit coucou pour la
ville de nice et bien sinon il y aura
marqué guingamp c'est pour guingamp
racing sur les passeurs d'aucuns vous
dit quoi bon après j'ai je suis parisien
slip ou caleçon qu'elles sont christophe
beaugrand ou matthieu delormeau baalbeck
t it
alors christophe beaugrand mathieu blanc
j'ai eu plus d'aventurés avec christophe
avoue préférer christophe d'accord très
bien
attention les 10 pôles vendredi les
marseillais août à la salle a été totale
à sa balle à ça arthur ou ou baba où
cyril hanouna
si tu dit arthur je te défonce les jo je
vais dire arthur tient moka soldats je
vous avez raison mais les deux ils sont
si colin claude c'est ce qu'on attendait
bon bah c'est bien évidemment vous
pouvez pas valérie bénaïm ou enora
malagré les deux en même temps c'est
bien l'école et l'autre